[Music]
2024 has arrived whether we like it or
not and to help you feel optimistic
about the fresh set of months ahead
let's look at T of Ron Tomato's most
anticipated movies of the year I'm
talking about some major sequels
adaptations and spin-offs that just
might make that hangover worth it after
all it's a super sized episode on this
week's or should I say this year's what
to watch it's only
[Music]
fragments nothing's clear arriving on
March one is Dune part two the second
part of director Den Vain's adaptation
of the iconic sci-fi novel will once
again feature the likes of Timothy
shalamay Josh broland Zena and others
but it's worth noting the new folks who
are joining the fun like Florence Pew
and Christopher Walkin which begs the
question are there cowbells on the
desert planet of oracus and if there was
one knock on the certified fresh first
film it's that it was lacking in the
action Department well this one promises
to be more action filled as shalam Paul
atraes tries to regain in control of his
Planet so yeah feel free to get excited
about this one Dune and movie fans
coming in late March is another big
sci-fi film Mickey 17 this is the latest
offering from writer director and
producer bong Jun ho who is pretty much
the biggest name in movies for a while
after parasite blew everyone's mind back
in 2019 this adaptation of Edward
Ashton's 2022 novel mickey7 is about a
disposable employee who is colonizing an
ice world and has a new body regenerated
with most of his memories intact
whenever he dies wowza and telling this
unique story is a cast that includes
Robert patson Steven young Tony Colette
and Mark Ruffalo double wowza I think
guys aware there's like a pretty huge
civil war going on all across America we
just try to stay out with what we see on
the news seems like it's for the best
also arriving in the spring will be the
action flick Civil War no not the
Captain America movie written and
directed by Alex Garland this movie
takes place in the near future as a team
of journalists travel the country during
a civil war war that is quickly
escalating due to a dystopian
dictatorship government uh are we sure
this is a good idea in an election year
also this is actually A2 24's most
expensive movie to date telegraphing
their Venture into producing more
commercial films but the most important
thing to note is that the one and only
Nick Offerman plays the president of the
United States finally I see
everything that is not
[Music]
everything hitting theaters in May is
kingdom of the Planet of the Apes as the
fourth installment in the rebooted
Planet of the Apes franchise this one
serves as a sequel to 2017 certified
fresh War of the Planet of the Apes and
this time it's director West ball from
The Maze Runner franchise who is pumping
new life into this epic Saga and while
the film stars Owen Teague and Freya
Allen will probably be familiar to you
this flick is all about the Apes and
their story as it takes place nearly 300
years after the previous film where apes
are the dominant species humans live in
the shadows and a Crazy Ape leader is
looking to build an Empire I'm F the
darkest of
[Music]
angels coming in hot at the end of May
will be furiosa a Mad Max Saga after
Charlie theon's furiosa character kind
of sort of stole the show in the 2015
hit madmax Fury Road director George
Miller is back 8 years later with this
prequel SL spin-off of that movie movie
it's about time this one will explore
furiosa's origin story with Anya Taylor
Joy stepping into the character she'll
be joined by Chris Hemsworth in a
supporting role as a young furiosa
survives many trials while trying to
find her way back home AKA another dopel
looking Race Across the desert hopefully
orange who made the console orange do I
look orange I didn't touch it orange is
not my color not
me hello getting emotional in June will
be the animated sequel inside out too
this is a follow-up to the 2015 very
certified fresh hit inside out from
Disney and Pixar with the main voice
cast of Amy polar Phyllis Smith and LS
black returning which is kind of a
enough said kind of thing but it is a
sequel and we'll be taking things up a
notch by introducing new emotions into
the mix now that young Riley is becoming
a full-blown team one of which is
anxiety the new character will be voiced
by newcast member Maya Hawk giving you
some theater air conditioning reprieve
right smack daav in the middle of summer
will be the long awaited Deadpool 3
after the previous two certified fresh
films were massive hits in 2016 and 2018
this one took a little bit of a detour
to get made as in Disney bought 20th
Century Fox Studios and now Marvel has
controlled the character meaning yes now
Deadpool is part of the MCU but perhaps
the biggest headline surrounding this
latest installment is the return of Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine which is going to
be super rat but don't forget that
Jennifer Garner is also returning to
Marvel as Electra after previously
appearing in 2003's Daredevil and 2005's
Electra dude is it summer yet just in
time for fall will be the sequel Joker
Folly ad after what was supposed to be a
one-off this is a somewhat surprising
followup to the Twisted take on the DC
villain from 2019 with director Todd
Phillips and star walking Phoenix
returning only this time it's a musical
and helping drive that point home even
more is the fact that pop star/ actress
Lady Gaga is playing Harley Quinn Who
develops an unhealthy obsession with
Arthur Fleck AKA Joker and I can't wait
to see what this means exactly in the
mind of Todd Phillips reent ENT in the
movie ring in November is the Epic
historical drama Gladiator 2 you heard
that right 24 years after Russell Crow
stared in the certified fresh original
director Ridley Scott is back with a new
story this time it follows the nephew of
waen Phoenix's comist character named
Lucius who is now a grown man after
being saved by crows maximus in the
first movie this time Paul mcal stars
with Denzel Washington and a supporting
role and Connie neelon and Derek jacobe
were prising their roles as Lucilla and
Senator grus respect respectively it's
going to be epic like literally adapting
into movie form in November is the
musical fantasy flick Wicked part one
directed by John mchu of crazy Rich
Asians Fame this is the first of a
two-part film adaptation of the stage
musical Wicked which of course is based
on a 1995 novel centering around
characters from the original book and
the 1939 movie so yeah it's an
adaptation of an adaptation based on an
adaptation you get it and telling the
story about how the Wicked Witch of the
West Rose to wickedness will be Stars
Cynthia rivo and Ariana Grande with Jeff
Goldblum and Michelle yo in supporting
roles um yes please if we click our
heels now do we get it sooner or later
or how does that work well there you
have it 10 picks to get you excited
about the year 2024 in movies be sure to
let us send your fellow viewers know in
the comments what you're most excited
for whether it was on this list or not
remember to check out Ron tomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay fresh